what advice could you give to young
people in high school and college given
the highest of stakes thing things
you've been thinking about
if somebody's listening to this and
they're young and trying to figure out
what to do with their career what what
to do with their life what advice would
you give them
don't expect it to be a long life don't
don't put your happiness into the future
the future is probably not that long at
this point but none know the hour nor of
the day
but is there something
if they want to have hope to fight for a
longer future is there something is
there a fight worth fighting
I intend to go down fighting
um
I don't know yeah
I I admit that although I do try to
think of painful thoughts the what what
to say to the children at this point is
a pretty painful thought as thoughts go
they they want to fight I I hired I
hardly know how to fight myself at this
point I
I'm
trying to be ready for
being wrong about something being
preparing for am I being wrong in a way
that that creates a bit of hope and
being ready to react to that and
and going looking for it and then that
is that is hard and complicated and
somebody in high school
um I don't know like you have presented
a picture of the future
that is not quite how I expect it to go
where there is public outcry and that
outcris is put into a remotely useful
Direction which I think at this point is
is just like shutting down the GPU
clusters
because no we are we are not in a shape
that like frantically do at the last
minute do decades worst of worth of work
I mean like the the thing you would do
at this point if there were massive
public outcry pointed in the right
direction which I do not expect is shut
down the GPU clusters and and crash
program on augmenting human intelligence
biologically not not for the stuff
biologically
because if you make humans much smarter
they can actually be smart and nice like
you you get that in a in a plausible way
in a way that you do not get that and it
is not as easy to do with synthesizing
these strings from scratch predicting
the next tokens and applying our RL HF
like humans start out in the frame that
that produces niceness that that has
ever produced niceness
and and
and in saying this I do not want to
sound like the moral of this whole thing
was like oh like you you need to engage
in mass action and then everything will
be all right
I I this is this is because there's so
many things where like somebody tells
you that the world is ending in like and
you need to recycle and if everybody
does their parting and recycles their
their cardboard then then we can all
live happily ever after and this and
this is not this is unfortunately not
what I have to say they're you know like
everybody
you know everybody recycling their
cardboard is not going to fix this
everybody recycles their cardboard and
then everybody ends up dead
um metaphorically speaking but if there
was enough like like like on the margins
you just end up dead a little bit later
on most of the things you can do that
are that that you know like a few people
can can do by like trying hard
but if there were if there was enough
public outcry to shut down the GPU
clusters and
yeah then then you then you could be
part of that outcry if Eliezer is wrong
in the direction that Lex Friedman
predicts that that there is enough
public outcry pointed enough in the
right direction to do something that
actually actually results in people
living
not just like we did something not just
there was an outcry and the outcry was
like given form and something that was
like safe and convenient and like didn't
really inconvenience anybody and then
everybody died everywhere there was
enough actual like oh we're going to die
we should not do that we should do
something else which is not that even if
it is like not super duper convenient it
wasn't inside the previous political
Overton window if there was that kind of
public if I'm wrong and there was that
kind of public outcry then somebody in
high school could be ready to be part of
that
if I'm wrong in other ways then you
could probably be part of that
but like
and if you if you're like a you know
like a brilliant young physicist then
you could like go into interpretability
and if you're smarter than that you
could like work on alignment problems
where it's harder to tell if you got
them right or not
and and other things but but most mostly
the kids in high school
um it's like yeah if it
if you know he had like
be ready for
to help if Ellie ezrautowski is wrong
about something and and otherwise
don't put your happiness into the far
future it probably doesn't exist but
it's beautiful that you're looking for
ways that you're wrong
and it's also beautiful that you're open
to being surprised by that same young
physicist
with some breakthrough it feels like a
very very basic competence that you are
praising me for and you know like okay
cool um
I I don't think it's good that that
we're in a world where that is something
that that I deserve to be complimented
on but I've never have I've never had
much luck in accepting compliments
gracefully maybe I should just accept
that one gracefully but sure well thank
you very much you've painted with some
probability a dark future are you
yourself just when you when you think
when you Ponder your life
and you Ponder your mortality
are you afraid of death
think so yeah
doesn't make any sense to you
that we die
like what
there's a power
to the finiteness of the human life
that's part of this whole machinery
of uh Evolution and that finiteness
doesn't seem to be obviously integrated
into it and AI systems
so it feels like almost some some
fundamentally in that aspect some
fundamentally different thing that we're
creating
I grew up reading books like great Mambo
chicken in the transhuman condition and
later on engines of creation and mine
children
um
you know like
age 12 or thereabouts so
I never thought I was supposed to die
after 80 years
I never thought that Humanity was
supposed to die I thought we were like
I always grew up with the ideal in mind
that we were all going to live happily
ever after in the Glorious transhumanist
future
I did not grow up thinking that death
was part of the meaning of life
and now and now I still think it's a
pretty stupid idea
but you do not need life to be finite to
be meaningful it just has to be life